[Musique]
il y avait de l'électricité dans l'air
ces derniers jours porte de versailles à
paris à l'occasion du salon de
l'automobile
tous les constructeurs tous ont présenté
des modèles électriques bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans dimanche en politique
votre émission de débat on franche comté
alors l'électrique sera-t-il un courant
porteur pour nos usines en franche comté
on vend débattre avec nos trois invités
je vous les présente tout de suite
d'abord alexandre boulanger vous êtes
journaliste spécialisé dans l'automobile
à l'est républicain au bureau de
montbéliard également sur ce plateau
bruno jamais du pôle véhicule du futur
pôle de compétitivité implantés
notamment à youtube vous vous dirigez le
programme énergie et propulsion c'est
vous qui avez en charge les questions
relevant des véhicules électriques et
puis alain pilarsky directeur général du
groupe né des qui gère plusieurs
concessions automobiles dans l'airé
urbaine
vous faites aussi de la recherche et
développement pour psa bonjour à tous
les trois merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors vous en avez l'habitude
vous pouvez participer à cette émission
interpeller nos invités nous faire part
de vos commentaires de vos questions sur
la page de l'émission ou commenter
l'émission tout au long du débat sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mot diez qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté alors
messieurs c'est donc une tendance forte
de ce salon de l'automobile 2018 qui
s'achève ce soir à paris tous les
constructeurs passent à l'électrique
alexandre bollengier
doit-on parler d'une révolution oui on
doit parler d'une révolution énergétique
les pouvoirs publics ont décidé de tuer
le diesel alors le diesel n'est pas tout
à fait mort l'encéphalogramme n'est pas
encore tout à fait plat il résiste même
assez bien aujourd'hui il faut à peu
près 40 % des immatriculations de
voitures neuves se font en diesel
c'était 73 % en 2013 donc la baisse est
quand même très importante mais elle
semble se stabiliser mais c'est vrai
qu'à terme avec les normes européennes
de rejet de co2 dans l'est dans les
années qui viennent
le diesel n'a pas d'avenir alors c'est
un choix une nécessité de passer à
l'électrique parce que vous parlez de la
décision de l'union européenne cette
semaine de limiter à 35 %
les émissions de co2 dans les années qui
viennent il ya eu aussi en tout début de
semaine le rapport du giec les experts
du climat sur l'onu qui a annoncé qu'il
fallait vraiment changer nos habitudes
sinon on courrait à la catastrophe donc
je vois où une nécessité les deux après
pour arriver à 35% enfin les eurodéputés
avaient proposé 40% lemistre
l'environnement heureux européen 35% et
la décision le pourcentage définitif
n'est pas encore arrêtée il doit l'être
théoriquement d'ici la fin de l'année
par par les états membres mais pour
arriver si on reste sur ce pourcentage
de 35% pour arriver à ce pourcentage
seul l'hybride et l'électrique permettra
de diminuer dans des proportions aussi
importantes le co2 les rejets de co2 par
an
bruno jamais révolution technologique oc
oui tout à fait et donc pour compléter
ce que disait monsieur l'an les
émissions de co2 qui sont prises en
compte sont les émissions entre le
réservoir du véhicule et la roue on
appelle ça les émissions du réservoir à
la roue et donc l'objectif qui est
définie jusqu'en 2030 c'est toujours du
réservoir à la roue
donc on pourra parler pourquoi pas de ce
qui se passe en amont pour la production
du carburant ou la production
d'électricité dont on parle le mix
énergétique
et puis après on pourra pourquoi pas
élargir sur tout ce qui est le cycle de
vie complet d'un véhicule alors
révolution oui et révolution parce qu'il
ya des facteurs qui est qui accélère
cette révolution les émissions de co2
pour répondre au seuil qui sont définies
au niveau européen en 2020 puis en 2025
puis en 2030
les constructeurs doivent absolument
trouver des solutions et cette solution
effectivement passe par
l'électrification croissante des chaînes
de traction
je vous faire réagir à une situation de
carlos tavares le grand patron de psa
il disait il ya quelques jours dans la
presse régionale je n'ai aucune réserve
sur l'électrification de l'automobile
mais at fort à force de ne suivre que
les impulsions et les moments d'émotion
ou de révolte on loupe des aspects
importants
alain pilarsky est-ce qu'on est dans un
effet de mode
alors quand le patron de psa nous parle
des motions d'impulsion oui c'est une
émotion parce qu'elle est dictée par des
impératifs qui sont avant tout des
impératifs politiques politique ou
écologique sous couvert d'écologie c'est
de la politique on s'abrite vers quelque
chose qui plaît qui est dans l'air du
temps qui est dans une dans une mouvance
qui est une tendance de fond qui est
inéluctable mais pour autant ce sont des
décisions politiques qui ne prennent pas
en compte toute toulan toute l'ampleur
du schéma pas nécessairement contre les
contraintes industrielles mais on pourra
plus facilement parler avec avec
d'autres amis qui ne prennent pas en
compte les contraintes de production de
haut niveau des batteries
les batteries sont aujourd'hui
majoritairement asiatiques elle utilise
des métaux rares des métaux précieux qui
sont en réserve non inépuisable qui se
sont essentiellement focalisés en
afrique
aujourd'hui la chine et en chine
la chine est omniprésente en afrique
pour ces raisons là elle donc elle capte
l'intégralité du marché
et qu'est ce qu'on fait au niveau
politique en europe on ne prend pas le
taureau par les cornes on n'a rien on
sait encore en matière de production de
batteries de nouvelle énergie nouvelle
batterie on va subir on va se mettre
vous êtes en train de me dire que c'est
une aberration dessus mentionné
l'électrique aussi bien écologiquement
que technologiquement parlant qui
s'éteint c'est un risque fou et puis
soyons clairs aujourd'hui on
subventionne électrique pour arriver à
ce que le coût d'acquisition d'un
véhicule électrique reste à peu près
acceptable pour le consommateur et 6000
euros aujourd'hui la prime ses équipes
ses 6000 euros pour un véhicule tout
électrique
ce consommateur aujourd'hui on se rend
compte qu'ils ont assez peu les moyens
de sur les véhicules puisque le parc
roulant est vieillissant il a pris un an
de plus il est passé à neuf en avant en
moyenne et en moyenne en deux en temps
ça veut dire que la capacité de
renouvellement du parc est extrêmement
ténu le secoue aujourd'hui fabrication
d'un véhicule électrique ou un véhicule
hybride
compte tenu du poids important des
batteries dans la danse coûts de
construction
c'est 30 à 35 % de plus qu'un véhicule
classique bien sûr que ça va évoluer si
on développe et si on vend plus de vécu
les critiques ça risque de baisser
mais c'est avec un risque c'est de se
mettre complètement dans les mains d'un
détenteur du marché et de celui qui
produit des batteries qui pourra et
aujourd'hui ce sont des producteurs
asiatiques et aujourd'hui qui font des
producteurs asiatiques
vous êtes d'accord un pari fou alexandre
boulanger carlos tavares et puis carlos
ghosn patron de renault au patron de
renault ont aussi soulevé ce problème de
des batteries et réclame la création
d'une filière européenne
la batterie c'est à peu près 40% du coût
de fabrication d'une voiture électrique
est ce que les constructeurs français
sont prêts à laisser un chéneau ou un
chaînon aussi important de la valeur du
véhicule à la chine c'est une vraie
c'est une vraie question est alors vous
parlez des patrons des constructeurs des
marques françaises c'est aussi le cas du
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui disait il ya quelques jours au salon
que l'idée de faire une filière de
l'indus l'automobile électrique avec des
composants uniquement asiatique ça n'a
aucun sens l'europe doit être
indépendante
aujourd'hui on en est loin mais parce
qu'on sera toujours dépendant aussi des
matières premières comme l'a dit
monsieur piraterie les terres rares et
des métaux rares donc sont
essentiellement enfin pour 40% je crois
sont localisés en chine elles sont
extraits dans des conditions écologiques
épouvantable avec l'utilisation de
produits chimiques acide sulfurique
alcide chlorhydrique dans les conditions
sociales épouvantable aussi avec des
salariés chinois qui gagne une misère
donc il faut prendre ça vraiment en
compte
bruno jamais le pas le tableau qui nous
est pas là n'est pas reluisant le défi
technologie qui peut être relevé par les
entreprises françaises
alors déjà je n'étais pas tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que
l'électrification soit une aberration
c'est par contre ce qui est une
aberration c'est que à partir
d'objectifs climatique de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre et à effet de serre
à partir d'objectifs de réduction de la
pollution locale les oxydes d'azoté les
particules
il ya tout un panel de solutions qui
existent et là où
il faut pas se tromper c'est vraiment
prenez une neutralité technologique
c'est les constructeurs qui proposeront
des solutions et les équipementiers tout
à fait l'air qui proposeront des
solutions à proposer des solutions avec
le couteau sous la gorge bull et la
politique
choisi par les différents états
notamment les états européens alors moi
je pense que c'est une chance
déjà qu'ils aient une dynamique
européenne parce que sinon on prêt il y
aurait toujours une personne qui
souhaiterait ou un état qui
souhaiteraient avancé moins vite donc là
il ya une dynamique européenne qui a
impulsé et avec une visibilité
on est en 2019 alors le temps industriel
c'est un temps long mais 2030
c'est pas demain demain on dans le
domaine industriel c'est 2025 on va dire
je ne suis pas certain que la visibilité
soit totale ou aussi clair qu'elle que
vous l'exprimez puisque une chose de
certaine et on a pu le constater dans la
ville dans le passé et dans le passé
récent également la variation des
inpulse politique sur l'incitation à
l'électrification des véhicules
les primes sont variantes elles sont un
moment donné de 6000 euros
elles étaient 9000 sur certains modèles
ne sont plus qu'à 1000 livres et ça a
disparu pour les brics à 10 ans parle de
la remettre
comment voulez vous qu'un consommateur
puisse s'y retrouver
comment voulez vous qu'on amène 30% des
acheteurs de véhicules neufs dans les
années qui viennent et les années qui
viennent cette demain c'est 2020 30%
c'est l'objectif de psa notamment 30% du
marché 1 30% du marché électrifiées ou
en totalité ou électrifié parce qu'il ya
des véhicules électrifiés jeudi
électrifié l'aï bride importants ou en
totalité électrique 30% des ventes de
ses véhicules en 2020
quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui le surcoût
le seul véhicule industriel donc le
surcoût commercial est compris entre 25
et 35% par rapport à un véhicule
classique que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
comment voulez vous que le consommateur
puisse s'engager résolument dans cette
dans cette démarche sans avoir de
certitude pérenne sur les moyens
d'accompagnement à la fois à
l'acquisition mais aussi sur le coût de
consommation en cours de route nous nous
trompons pas aujourd'hui le carburant
tel que nous le connaissons carburants
fossiles gasoil essence est hyper taxés
en france
avez-vous fait le calcul du différentiel
de taxes si le parc roulant demain
passer à 30% milliards il ya moins de
recettes pour l'état moins de recettes
pour l'état ils vont forcément les
retrouver et ils vont forcément l'airé
impacter sur l'électrique
de quelle manière on ne sait pas on a
pas de lisibilité et vous voulez que les
consommateurs s'engagent dans ce sens là
sans ordonner de visibilité c'est
extrêmement délicat une réaction de
mathieu je pense que l'électrique est
davantage un effet de mode qu'une
solution écologiques à long terme
mathieu qui s'interroge sur le côté
positif de la démarche lui égard la
pollution très importante je le lien
générés par la fabrication des batteries
lithium voulait répondre parce que
jamais en fait en termes de pollution
déjà effectivement il ya des les
batteries de générations actuelles ont
des approvisionnements en métaux en
terres rares en lithium cobalt etc qui
sont extraites dans des conditions qui
ne sont pas celles de l'europe
on va dire et donc c'est un problème et
ensuite c'est un prime sociale alors le
relais même sociale mais aussi un
problème économique c'est à dire que
comme c'était dit précédemment les
batteries si jamais on est plus que des
assembleurs de batteries plus un petit
moteur électrique et une carrosserie en
france par exemple ça va poser un
problème sur l'industrie après il ya le
point de vue de clients très très bien
et donc dans le domaine des batteries
que dit l'europe c'est effectivement
positionnons sur positionnement nous sur
les cellules de batterie pour ne plus
les acheter en chine ou en corée au
japon mais pas sur la génération
actuelle parce que les concurrents
internationaux ont déjà des outils de
production extrêmement efficace donc
c'est plutôt la quatrième génération de
batteries qui est une nouvelle
génération dans lequel les proportions
de lithium de cobalt sont différentes et
à terme il ya la volonté bien sûr de
supprimer totalement
certaines matières qui font l'objet de
tensions c'est l'objet du rapprochement
notamment récent entre psa et le
fabricant japonais nidec c'est ça alors
ça c'est pour fabriquer des moteurs
électriques justement en région grand
est et donc c'est ça a du sens
effectivement de dire quelle partie de
la chaîne de valeur du véhicule
est-ce qu'on va investir sur la batterie
ce moteur électrique toute
l'électronique de puissance qui va
alimenter cette puissance qui est énorme
une habitation on va dire que vous avez
des puissances en jeu entre 1 et 3
kilowatts un véhicule électrique c'est
80 cents 200 kg attaqué des puissances
énorme et donc voilà
le moteur la batterie et puis toute
l'électronique tout un champ que les
bourses docteur choisissent d'investir
donc il faut travailler sur une nouvelle
génération de batteries pour
s'affranchir des problèmes et de la
concurrence asiatique on a bien compris
une fois que ces batteries sont
popularisées avec les véhicules sont
vendus
est ce que la france par exemple a les
moyens d'alimenter toutes ces batteries
notamment des images inondé recharge de
x milliers de véhicules la nuit est ce
que il faut pas c'est pas une aberration
aussi en termes d'alimentation et de et
de recharge de ces voitures électriques
sans oublier le transport d'électricité
alors ceux qui aujourd'hui nous
permettra en fait il ya deux choses en
termes d'infrastructures il ya le
l'énergie que vous avez transféré en
moyenne sur une journée et après il ya
les pics de puissance par exemple on
sait qu'en hiver vers 18h ou 19h il ya
un pic de puissance consommée par en
france et donc en fait dans la recharge
des véhicules électriques à batterie on
pourra parler pourquoi pas de
l'hydrogène et des piles à combustible
qui est également un véhicule électrique
on a soit les recharge lente donc qui
ont un impact - et contre guimet sur le
réseau électrique où on allait recharge
rapide pour faire croire aux
effectivement je suis assez prudent par
rapport à ça pour faire croire qu'un
conducteur pourra recharger à 100 200 ou
300 50 kilowatts 350 kg watts et on veut
dire si on dit qu'une l'habitation
consomme en moyenne 500 watts vers 3 150
kilowatts c'est comme si quand vous
branchez votre véhicule électrique en
charge rapide vous aviez 700 habitations
qui se mettait à en consommer
d'électricité donc c'est quelque chose
qui est énorme et pour le réseau
électrique c'est compliqué il faut
qu'ils aient vraiment l'énergie qui est
disponible
c'est pas forcément un problème par
contre les pics de puissance quand on va
se mettre à recharger de façon rapide
parce qu'on n'a pas envie de laisser
aujourd'hui même dans le sur le domaine
public qui met enfin il ya très peu de
bornes de recharge
après il est là et là c'est aussi du
politique imaginons un départ en
vacances grandes baies période de
grandes de grandes transhumances
estivales vous avez sur l'autoroute une
vague ont enfin des wagons successifs de
véhicules électriques ou hybrides qui
nécessite un rechargement qui vont tous
se précipiter dans les bornes
même si on dit que le tendre de
chargement va s'accélérer besoin passer
à 40 minutes avec certaines bornes la
queue derrière et puis comment vous
faites pour recharger votre voiture
quand vous habitez un appartement
n'avait pas tiré une rallonge depuis le
5ème étage jusque jusque là rue où se
trouvaient deux voix d'où l'importance
des bornes voilà quand vous avez à
disposition de tous vous avez vous
habitez dans serein dans un plain pied
une maison vous pouvez facilement
branchez votre voiture j'ai bien compris
les réticences qu'il y avait notamment
de ce côté ci du plateau sur la voiture
électrique néanmoins là ça y est tous
les constructeurs s'y mettent c'est une
des monde y va on a évidemment le ps à
qui est un peu le moteur dans la région
un peu beaucoup d'ailleurs qu'ici mais
qui promet 100 % des nouveaux modèles
électriques ou hybrides ans en 2019
qu'est-ce que ça va changer alexandre
boulanger sur le tissu économique est
d'abord sur les usines psa de la région
déjà le développement de l'hybride
rechargeable et d'electric ça se fait à
belchamp et puis elle centre de
recherche et développement à côté de
sochaux
tout à fait et puis vous avez vu il ya
un mois aussi il ya eu une présentation
de la stratégie électriques de psa avec
la visite du l'atelier l'atelier qui qui
en fait il est entre un atelier 4 1 de
tester la fluidité du montage des
véhicules hybrides et en fait c'est un
atelier pilote pour l'ensemble des
usines mondiales pour l'ensemble des
usines que personne possédant le monde
donc alexandre bollengier psa c'était le
roi du diesel 1 et ça a pris du retard
sur la plupart de ces gros concurrents
sur l'électrique ps à peu le combler ce
retard
en tout cas oui oui oui oui je suis pas
certain qu'on puisse parler de retard de
personnes retard sur les technologies
anciennes c'est à dire que on est sur
des technologies qui évoluent tellement
vite c'est pas pénalisant d'être partis
un peu plus tard que les horaires les
moteurs diesel effectivement à l'image
de diesel qui colore beaucoup à ps1 mais
faut pas oublier des moteurs essence qui
sont excellents tout à fait nous était
sortie récemment des moteurs à 8,6
good evil 2 mai dernier plusieurs
reprises voilà tout à fait donc là c'est
quelque chose sur lequel psa est très
performant et puis ils investissent dans
les moteurs électriques avec l'idée que
investissent avec punch powertrain dans
les boîtes de vitesses pour véhiculer le
guardian ils sont prêts mais vous
monsieur jamais au pôle véhicule du
futur votre vote rails notamment cette
coordonnées de créer des synergies entre
toutes les entreprises du secteur
automobile notamment sur ces questions
là est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
que notamment en franche comté
on y travaille et que ça ça va être une
source d'emploi par exemple alors mais
il ya deux choses en fait au niveau
français il ya un chiffre qui circule
qui dit que pour fabriquer un moteur
diesel il faut cette fois plus
d'ouvriers que frau fabriquer un moteur
électrique
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une
transformation qui va avoir lieu et
ensuite dire que l'écosystème est prêt
oui en fait ça fait plusieurs années que
globalement il se prépare la question
c'est qu'il soit prêt c'est une chose
mais que le marché le demande
c'est une autre chose est en fait c'est
la conjonction du fait qu'il ya un
marché et un produit disponible
alors donc le pôle véhicule du futur on
travaille bien sûr avec l'automobile
mais également avec des constructeurs
autres tels que alstom et donc alstom et
ils ont une réflexion très simple c'est
ils peuvent faire des locomotives à
hydrogène comme ça a été lancé récemment
en allemagne mais ils disent ok donc sur
une locomotive à hydrogène je pourrais
ce le vendre tel prix je pourrais ça me
coûterait tel prix et le marché j'en
vendrais convient et en fait il a besoin
d'une visibilité dans ce marché là et
sinon or pour l'instant
et donc ils sont prêts ils sont dans les
starting blocks mais en fait c'est le
même problème en automobile on voit là
derrière vous et puis on l'a vu on l'a
vu à l'image le fameux concept car là il
est jeune crée une 504 visite et qu'il
est tout électrique autonome là alors je
sais pas s'il ya une demande pour les
véhicules électriques
mais cette voiture-là eu un certain
succès alexandre boulanger vous l'avez
vu vous allez avoir avalé oui oui oui
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une influence
de journalistes pendant les journées
presque était assez impressionnante
après il ya le côté nostalgique qui joue
beaucoup parce que elle reprend les
lignes la 504 qui fête ses 50 ans cette
année
mais c'est vrai donc chaîne de traction
100% il
xxi sont km d'autonomie autonome avec un
volant qui se rétracte et qui laisse la
place à un très grand écran de 49 plus
que comme c'est au tour dont on pourra
regarder la télé pendant qu'on roule
devant d'orly sont fait enrôler
cette voiture si vous permettez est là
elle embarque toute la mutation que
l'ensemble de la chaîne ou tobin de la
production jusqu'à la distribution il ya
usage va connaître dans les années qui
viennent
c'est un véhicule qui est connecté mais
des véhicules sont tous connectés depuis
déjà quatre ans c'est un véhicule qui va
être autonome et ça c'est pour demain
dans trois ou quatre ans quand on aura
réglé les problèmes administratifs et
surtout règle réglementaire et
administratif en termes de
responsabilité et elle embarque la
chaîne cinématique électrique des
batteries qui se clipse ont préfiguré
comme étant de troisième ou de quatrième
génération
donc c'est véritablement le symbole du
véhicule du futur mais surtout de la
mutation besoin d'un train de vivre
c'est le symbole du du temps partagé
c'est le symbole de la mobilité partagée
c'est donc toute cette nouvelle mobilité
qui arrivent et qui va nous faire
connaître encore des changements
extrêmement profond pour lequel il faut
qu'on se prépare et pour lequel nous
sommes père c'est déjà très sur le plan
technologique les réseaux de
distribution commence à se préparer à se
mettre en dimensions ce qui nous
concerne pour le groupe cadets s'est
déjà fait aussi sur ce schéma là mais
c'est vraiment ablement un projet futur
je vous donne la parole alexandre
boulanger juste une réflexion de l'udc
qui m'a fait sourire je vous avoue le
tout électrique ça me rappelle une autre
époque le tout diesel évitant de faire
la même erreur apprenons du passé on en
est loin du tout électrique quand même
parce que là effectivement on se
focalise là-dessus mais ça représente
quoi
1% des ventes aujourd'hui 5 % du monde
et puis on sait pas si pourri le 4 4 %
si on prend les hybrides rechargeables
voilà donc ça reste très flou et enfin
ça reste très faible alors on glose sur
la fin du diesel mais c'est encore 40%
des ventes
et puis et puis que fait-on du parc
roulant actuelle que fait-on du parc
roulant alors je vais prendre un exemple
simple sur mon périmètre de
responsabilité parce que je le connais
bien
dray nous livrons chaque année entre nos
corps nos ventes propre est celle que
nous les livraisons que nous faisons
pour les collaborateurs ps1 et qui
viennent prendre livraison d'un véhicule
chez nous allez on va dire simplement
douze mille véhicules par an 9
même si on passe demain avec ça il ya
30% de ses ventes l'inde qui vont être
en réguler hybrides ou électriques
le vin c'est 2020 je le répète et ça
vous n'avez aucun doute là dessus vous
qu'il vendait des ss alors ça va être
cette vente des voitures ça va être une
obligation de toute façon nous n'aurons
pas d'autres d'autre alternative que d'y
parvenir
et il est sans liant les particuliers
sont prêts à ça alors on va accompagner
les particuliers vers 7 vers cette
reconnaissance l'hybride je pense que ne
pas y avoir trop de difficultés parce
que c'est quelque chose qui va répondre
aux besoins et qui va être un bon
accompagnement pour l'accompagnateur
dando transition pour aller vers
l'électrique
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
pour maîtriser parce qu'ils ont encore
la capacité de maîtriser la distance une
à distance utile mais ça va représenter
combien de véhicules électriques dans
une année si vous avez des jeux continue
sa tente au maximum 3600 sur une année
le parc roulant de véhicules de moins de
huit ans que nous avons dans notre
périmètre de responsabilité de cent
mille voitures va 30 ans pour renouveler
son parc brno jamais vous demandez là
l'apparent que je vous lirai
effectivement donc il ya nombre de
véhicules qui est assez faible en parc
du fait qu'on arrive avec un flux de
nouveaux véhicules dans un parc qui est
très important et c'est vrai que même
avec des chiffres de nouveaux véhicules
électriques ou électrifiée qui serait
important
on arrive en 2035 à des prévisions de 20
ou 30 % de véhicules électriques
et puis encore pas mal de véhicules
essence ou diesel voilà mais du fait de
l'inertie de renouvellement de
sauvegarde a fait un mini série que la
question c'est un outil si l'hybride
rechargeable c'est c'est une étape vers
l'électrique ou si c'est une fin en soi
et ça c'est plus le consommateur qui
décidera hunting high and vincent le
directeur industriel le dit d'une
certaine façon sûre au niveau
technologique a pas vraiment de
soucieuse souci à se faire pour psa mais
il met mais psa ne maîtrise pas du tout
la vitesse à laquelle ce changement va
opérer ça c'est un gros gros problème et
il hésite mais les usines
sont prêtes je veux dire on a parlé de
l'atelier prototype mais c'est
exportable partout et à grande échelle
oui parce combien de fois les
plateformes jolie sont structurés sont
là donc la plateforme c'est ce qu'ils
supportent véhicule est structuré pour
permettre deux plateformes aujourd'hui
pour psa et et elles sont communes à
toutes les toutes les marques et les
conséquences sur l'emploi alexandre
boulanger bois n'ont jamais nous disait
on pour cette façon vous avez vu les
effectifs de psa en cdi ne cesse de
diminuer et on est tombé fin août sous
les 7000 sous les 8000 pardon cdi alors
parlé de sochaux 2 sochaux on nous parle
de sochaux et avec un volant de
d'intérimaires toujours très élevé donc
il n'ya pas de raison pour que la décrue
ne se pose se poursuive pas une dernière
question d'un internaute guillaume qui
nous dit la voiture électrique est une
vraie fausse solution tant que l'on
invente rappaz des batteries qui ne
pollue pas pour moi la seule solution
c'est le vélo traditionnel
finalement est-ce qu'il n'est pas vain
derrière ce débat de chercher une
voiture propre
oui une voiture sera jamais sans bien
comprendre je n'ai jamais vu un avis
tout à fait clair là dessus c'est que
les batteries actuelles effectivement
écologiquement ne permettent pas un
bilan favorable on va dire mais
néanmoins il faut pas reculer parce qu'
à l'instant t il y a un bilan
défavorable
j'étais en chine au fin juin où donc on
parlait de véhicule électrique véhicule
hydrogène et donc j'ai posé la question
mais quelle est la source de production
de votre électricité
donc là il était un peu bredouille mais
je leur dit soyez en confiance c'est une
tendance sur une tente centrale est
située une tendance à partir des
énergies renouvelables etc
ce n'est pas un prétexte pour ne rien
faire parce que il faut avoir des
émissions nulles à usage émission notre
véhicule électrique à terme qu'il soit
alimenté par des batteries ou par d
hydrogène pile à combustible
et puis on les batteries vont évoluer
aussi et les solutions hydrogène pile à
combustible je vais préciser en fait
l'hydrogène c'est un vecteur de stockage
d'énergie qui est beaucoup plus dense
que les batteries et donc en fait
naturellement il ya tout un ensemble de
véhicules qui seront tout à fait adapté
avec des batteries et tout un ensemble
de véhicules qui seront tout à fait
adapté avec des solutions de stockage
sous forme d'hydrogène qui est
transformée en électricité eau qui aura
pas une solution et une seule une
solution technique et l'hydrogène ce qui
est important c est ça le travaille sur
une plateforme hydrogène en tout temps
tout à fait pour en fait des entreprises
comme comme la poste pour détourner du
l'état de l'accord d'entreprise comme ça
on part du duo on part on part et on
arrive au même endroit donc pour les
recharges c'est ça ta s'est dit les
choses n'ont pas besoin d'un réseau d'un
réseau d'un réseau de recharge est
justement sur la franche comté est ce
que c'est important savoir la franche
comté dans le domaine de l'hydrogène et
des piles à combustible est très en
pointe et donc c'est une chance de
pouvoir saisir cette force on va pas on
va capitaliser sur nos forces avant de
vouloir inventer d'autres choses et
l'hydrogène et les piles à combustible
c'est un système beaucoup plus riches
ça fait appel à des usineurs des
emboutisseurs des fabricants de
réservoir en composite et donc on a une
transformation beaucoup plus maîtrisé de
de l'industrie française avec on gardera
cette note positive pour conclure cette
émission merci à tous les trois ans est
terminée suis désolé s'est terminée
merci à tous les trois j'espère qu'on
vous aura éclairer un peu sur ses
véhicules électriques dans un instant
flashs d'information et puis après
dimanche en politique continue avec
francis letellier qui reçoit benoît
hamon bon dimanche